what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here joined by
YouTuber philanthropist communist
Michael B Rob from Omni media what's
going on buddy
doing all right man uh working on my
communist plans to take over the world
you know and all that in this in my
spare time you guys should follow
Michael B on his YouTube channel
omnimedia he's he's seriously one of the
best we really liked episode one quite a
bit
um watching ahsoka's origin story
of her taming animals and then uniting
with them to kill her family like the
original Jungle Book
um did you know that's what happens in
The Jungle Book Michael yeah
I was thinking it was like I was like is
this are we having some Bambi parallels
and then I was like is this now Jungle
Book I was like what's going on here are
they gonna Disney are they gonna Disney
mom her and that's what I would say yeah
go ahead and leave a like uh subscribe
click the notification Bell to get
notified when a reaction for the next
episode is up we are binging these right
now Reaction watch the Longs we single
put their own copy tales of the Jedi
available at our patreon page but enough
Chit Chat let's get to it
foreign
[Music]
yeah we'll be arriving shortly Master
set us down well clear of the village
tensions are high enough is that who I
think it is that's a little Qui-Gon
Qui-Gon gin right yeah it looks like
Mark Hamill
I see it now for sure it's like some
wrapping my head around it
[Music]
oh this oh poor poor Droids on its last
legs
while we're at on this planet
[Music]
we don't want your kind around here
there there there there there
I thought that feels very Gothic about
this yeah
yeah I was thinking I got like a really
strong Witcher Vibes out of nowhere for
some reason where are they holding the
Senator's son
why should we tell you
he sounds like Alan Rickman yeah allow
me to make my intentions clear
Jedi
we are here to help resolve the
situation very uh
for the senator threat forward Jedi
negotiation tactic right there
he is one of the longest standing
senators in the Republic and when you
enter this Village you could see the
effects of his long-standing policies if
you don't like him why not elect a new
Senator I wish it were that simple
yeah man you would know better
I will show you where the Senator's son
is
oh you keep going put in the politics in
Our Star Wars man
[Music]
they all are
I like that young Qui-Gon kind of sounds
like young Eva McGregor very curious
about this one with the the title
Justice and Dooku yeah I know he's gonna
deliver some justice have you been
treated well
for a prisoner yes besides I have two
ton here to keep me company
it's like a buff Wally
I rarely leave the capital when I do I
spend time off world on course hunt not
here how could my father allow this to
happen to his people you don't blame
them for abducting you
what choice do they have you are the
best hostage yeah he's like these ties
can be tighter
[Music]
traitor
arrest these criminals and have them
release my son at once
I'm afraid our investigation is not yet
complete Senator
investigation
they abducted my son I demand his
release judge
this episode has a great grasp on its
tone I know man step aside Jedi
we cannot
[Music]
serve the Senate uh no what about that
they serve the people of this Republic
[Applause]
[Music]
oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
guys just let the Jedi handle it yeah
dude we're good just duck behind the
barn
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop
cut both their heads off
God man
I'd watch a whole Dooku series dude me
too just Dooku and Qui-Gon how to watch
the whole thing how could you do this
these are your people
our people
but they're poor but if I get them out
of my sight they won't be in my mind
it's just the thing about Dooku
is like the more he grows and sees the
world the more the corruption of it
sickens him because he's always kind of
resented the Jedi for not doing enough
now you're it shows you the the
perceived injustices of the world that's
what pushed him I wonder if any
meaningful change will come of this
is that why you took action into your
own hands your actions saved many lives
today us thinking in the moment Master
you're a much wiser man than I
qui-gonjin
thanks to your teachings
I am sorry for throwing you against the
barn door it's Qui-Gon
it was for your own good
it was a lesson to be learned oh God
that's great like that one yeah that was
great it had such a great grasp once
it's like what really registered with me
on this one especially watching the
first and second one back to back is you
know like the Clone Wars Episodes uh
they're they're kind of like uh they're
not an anthology but that you know like
they would I don't I never quite knew
how to describe Clone Wars because they
it could hop around different types of
different stories you know just focus on
certain sets of characters for a certain
period of time and it it feels like some
stores are plucked out of during the
Clone Wars time and so there's something
appropriate about doing an anthology
tale
um you know within the the kind of the
Clone Wars Vibe and aesthetic and and uh
in some ways these are just sort of
shorter episodes of a Clone Wars episode
and but but a complete short film like
they feel like complete short films with
uh and so they have to come they have to
really communicate you know it's it's
tone right away and its mood and
atmosphere
instantaneously so that we can get away
with a shorter run time without it
feeling like incomplete or unsubstantial
but I thought they did a great job at a
community like effectively communicating
this because
you know like while we get to spend more
time with Dooku and Clone Wars and of
course the the two movies
this was the first real time I was like
oh you know
there was a good guy in him and it just
got just got pushed to the edge and and
I like how
I like how it stems so much from not
just wanting to do evil things because
it's really easy to chalk up Dooku as to
like it just became evil he became
Christopher Lee
he he's he he's so good at playing evil
people yeah maybe you see that you know
they're what like seeing something like
this where
the things that pushed him were watching
truly bad Deeds Done to good people and
and ultimately that's what pushed him to
the dark side so I just think that's an
interesting thing and of course you know
just see him and Qui-Gon kicking it this
is nice it's nice what'd you think yeah
man I I really enjoyed it like I agree
with everything you said like I just
love that so much of this too is
there's so between this and the last one
so far I mean we're
where we've only watched these two up to
this point but like so far they do so
much with just the visuals yeah with
just the composition of the shots the
pace the mood the tone there's so much
being conveyed that's just not verbal
exactly that is just so enthralling that
I I want
like I'm getting lost in the sauce just
watching yeah these things unfold
and I I just
I want to stay there you know and I I
get what you're it's hard to
I know what you're trying to say but I
also don't know how to say it awesome
where they're they're serialized but
they're also kind of anthological in the
way that sometimes we just show up and
we we spend some times in these very
small Pockets yeah exactly but like it's
all about
I feel like with Clone Wars it feels
more
um
like it feels obligated to get right
into the beat of the action yeah and to
sustain the audience's attention
but like this is really just allowing us
to kind of breathe in the atmosphere so
one of the things I really liked about
some of the more off the like off kilter
uh Visions yeah exactly episodes that we
had like the uh
shoot I think it was six the one with
the village just the way that whole
thing was about the people about the
setting and about
coming out and that's kind of like what
Dooku was doing here it was like it was
this slow
he's there to help
but he's also not going to be a pushover
yeah he's he's a man of action
because my as oh it's just
yeah it was it was beautiful I think I
think these like fit within clone wars
in its own in its own way uh it just as
opposed to spending several episodes of
man I I was watching this like
it would be cool to watch like a whole
season of Television just about Dooku
and and Qui-Gon and
what happened with their friend their
their relationship you know and again
you see baby Obi One
young young little everyone oh man that
would be so that would be a lot of fun
and then Qui-Gon looks at him and goes
hello there
oh my God
hello there I've been wondering why he
always said it just like that
but what if he actually had learned it
from Dooku oh damn it's evil quite he
learned it from Yoda and it was actually
their hello oh [ __ ]
hey coming off of this like I know we
probably got more Dooku
down the line with this but like this uh
because I was talking to you like before
this about you know
trying to like get in the groove for
these shorts and stuff so like I was
really deep into uh Dooku Jedi lost
and like you can see because that goes
from when he becomes a Padawan
up into where he really kind of really
loses Faith with the Jedi
um and you see
kind of like all of these different
things because this is like right
because once uh Qui-Gon becomes a master
I think if I remember right that's
that's really when he's like all right
I've done my duty I'm done with you guys
I'm out
yeah but there's you see so much of that
what he wants the Jedi to be
behind those eyes in here
it's just so beautifully done it with
with like no words well you know like
and it does go to serve a lot of because
some once in a while you do get because
like we you know everyone loves the Jedi
the Jedi or the [ __ ] in Star Wars uh but
then once in a while you travel the
places in in the Galaxy where people are
like the Jedi don't do [ __ ] for me
they're always up in like course not
just chilling and protecting rich folks
you know like they they feel like they
could be more involved and be more
helpful and while we do get those
stories as well and you know like
obviously you know that's just I'm
talking about perspective that some some
of the characters in Star Wars do adopt
depending on their circumstances and
where they are in this world or this
universe and this really goes goes to
serve that you know like they're there
on a mission to save the senator son
when you find out like oh you know what
it's yeah they're they're answering
something on behalf of the political
figure but really it's the people who
are in trouble and not the senator even
the senator Sons like my dad's a dick
you know yeah like like the whole the
they they attacked the root of the
problem
rather than the symptom yeah in this
like the the they were there because the
kid got kidnapped but then why did the
kid get kidnapped because the the their
leaders not listening to their plight so
what they start going down the rabbit
hole to that instead of just like okay
well I can give you some Acetaminophen
and just like kick you out
but like the affection's still there
yeah it's like therapy I don't know yeah
they therapized this place so that's not
a thing I don't think Clone Wars got too
deep into was
Dooku's side of things because a lot of
the time in Clone Wars he was just like
well he was here today
so like I just I love anytime any any
time we can spend uh giving our villains
a little dimension
yeah I would like uh I I'd be really
down for like a Dooku uh tale because it
this one really intrigued me and as much
as I'm you know like I want them to keep
doing newer things in Star Wars this was
one I'm like well let's go back let's
see what happened here this would be
actually pretty interesting to watch
because I was I was really compelled by
this few minutes
um but yeah all right guys what'd you
think about this episode leave your
thoughts down below go ahead uh
subscribe click that notification Bell
check us on patreon you can follow
Michael Buble people call you that
because your last name what's your last
name
do you say it no you publicly don't put
it out there that's a that's a problem
that's a conscientious Choice it is it's
actually Michael Buble isn't it
[Laughter]
and people have just made fun of you
your whole life
it's more about my initials though it's
the MLB so like I can't get away from
the Major League baseballs uh uh
I did not know it was MLB it is
oh wait I know your last name I will not
say it yeah I just I just remember it
right now
anyway all right guys well thanks for
being here we're gonna move on to the
next episode
foreign